-Our next guest is
an Argentinean superstar
who's making her U.S. TV debut.
Performing "Wapo Traketero"
and "No Toque Mi Naik"
with special guest Lunay,
here's Nicki Nicole!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ U u u u ♪
♪ U u u ♪
-♪ Wapo traketero ♪
♪ Siempre quiere verme ♪
♪ Y dice que es un santo ♪
♪ Pero es un delincuente ♪
♪ Y que hay que delinquir
pa' poder tenerte ♪
♪ Que hay que poner pila'
pa' poder tenerme ♪
♪ Quiero to'a la money,
quiero una medalla ♪
♪ Por descartar giles
que no dan la talla ♪
♪ Vo' estás estresa'o,
sonando en alta ♪
♪ Que la cuenten esos haters,
no le' da la nafta ♪
♪ Tener lo que presumen
jamás me hizo falta ♪
♪ Casi sin querer,
lo mío se destaca ♪
♪ Y wapo traketero ♪
♪ Siempre quiere verme ♪
♪ Y dice que es un santo, ya ♪
♪ Pero es un delincuente ♪
♪ Wapo traketero ♪
♪ Siempre quiere verme ♪
♪ Y dice que es un santo, ya ♪
♪ Pero es un delincuente ♪
-♪ Wapo traketero ♪
-♪ A la la la ♪
-♪ Siempre quiere verme ♪
♪ Mjm, m ♪
Lunay.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
♪♪
♪ Como sabes, yo no soy
de las que tanto la meten ♪
♪ Igual no molestaría
si no me comprometes tú ♪
♪ Y yo hacemos lo que quieras ♪
♪ Pero sabe que conmigo
después de eso pichaera ♪
♪ Ando en el sky ♪
♪ En la peli
como "Rich or Die" ♪
♪ Mami, somos
Bonnie and Clyde ♪
♪ Pero en esta vuelta
con Naik ♪
♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
-♪ No me pises las Naik
[audio drop] ♪
♪ Tú no ves cómo brilla ♪
♪ Contigo que lo cojan
por la orilla ♪
♪ Si tiran las malas
son un par de mordías ♪
♪ Lo hacen porque saben
que estamos al día, ah ah ♪
♪ Hace tiempo
que llueven los ceros ♪
♪ Ehh, hace tiempo que
no me importan los cueros ♪
♪ Lluvia de diamante,
se siente el aguacero ♪
♪ Si la baby no es
de Argentina, no la quiero ♪
♪ Si no vas a fumar,
entonces pasa el [audio drop] ♪
♪ Ella vino a perrear
pa' la disco tranquili ♪
♪ Te puede costar
pero no se va con trili ♪
♪ Ella se enfoca en pichar
y estar chilling ♪
-♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
-♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
-♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
-♪ Yo no soy lo que buscas ♪
♪ Yo tengo mala fama ♪
-♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
-♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
-♪ Así que, mami, estamos redi
pa'l pari, pero ♪
-♪ Ehh, no toque mi Naik,
ehh, no ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik, pero ♪
♪ No toque mi Naik ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]